[Music]
welcome to
session 53 of the worlds of speculative
fiction
series this is an ongoing monthly series
in which we
discuss narrative universes that are
quite
rich and we explore some philosophical
themes there's often a lot of discussion
of the reception of the works and
biography and a whole bunch of other
stuff rolled into it as well
this time around we are going to be
looking at the
first three books in the world of tears
series assembled in this single volume
here those are a maker of universes the
gates of creation
and a private cosmos the world of tears
is one of philip jose farmer's
major series you might also know him
from the day world series or
from the river world series but the
world of tears
is is in some ways the most influential
of these
and there are two volumes in the series
there's actually another spin-off book
that we'll talk about in a little bit as
well
so we're going to be looking at these
these three earliest novels you could
say behind the walls of tara
deserves to be lumped in with these for
reasons that we'll talk about in just
just a few minutes
pertaining to his biography and the
order of the writing but we're gonna
go with with two different sessions
session 53 on this volume
session 54 on this volume next month
and you know it's a progressive series
there's new ideas new characters being
introduced
so it works out quite well there are a
lot of philosophical themes
involved in the world of tears and it
turned out to be
quite influential not only on other
sci-fi writing but also
on you know dungeons and dragons to a
certain extent and role-playing games as
a result
on you know ideas that that filtered
into
television for example you'll you'll
recognize a number of different themes
within this series
in stargate if you're into that
narrative
universe at all and so there's a lot to
say about about farmers work
i'll tell you a little bit about how i
got into
farmer and particularly this series
before we jump into talking about the
development of the series
and some biographical stuff and then
jumping into a lot of
narrative universe and philosophical
themes so
i first encountered philip jose farmer
as you know one of those cool sci-fi
slash fantasy writers that fit into what
they call the new wave
of of science fiction that also included
like harlan ellison
and ursula kayla greene and you know i
guess you could say philip k
dick fitz in there and rogers zelazny
and michael morcock
and farmer you know as a
middle schooler and high schooler
there's a lot of sex and farmer's
stories as a matter of fact he's very
well known
for being one of the people to bring
sexuality
and in some cases quite vivid sexual
description
into uh into that that genre
right and so that was that was part of
the interest but he's also a great
storyteller right
and so i read um
some of the river world series and some
of his short stories and then i
actually checked out one of the
world of tears books from the library i
believe that i
actually started with behind the walls
of
tara because i think red orc was already
involved in it and
it was it was pretty cool you know i
enjoyed it he's a storyteller there's a
fast pace to the
narrative that's going on there's a lot
of cool ideas
involved in it especially for somebody
uh who's who's you know a teenager
not just the sexuality stuff but all the
other themes that we're going to talk
about
in a bit and i read through some of them
but i didn't read through the entire
series
um always wanted to go back to them
when i started doing the worlds of
speculative fiction series i i
considered actually doing world of tears
but then i decided to do
river world instead because it was you
know a bit better known
at that time in you know the the
you could say the internet world and
i remember enjoying the river world and
reading you know several of the the
volumes but not having read my way all
the way through it
so we did that and that was
either in year one or year two if you go
back through the playlist you can easily
find it and you know i always thought
well it'd be cool to go back to
doing this series as well and so
my 50th birthday i created an amazon
list because you know 50 is kind of a
big deal
and i do have a lot of fans and
subscribers and supporters who wanted to
get me something from my 50th and i put
this i put these two books into my
wish list and i forget who got them for
me but i
i was really thankful that they did and
i read my way through them oh back
around
september it's now june
and so you know now i'm going through
my second full rereading of the series
and enjoying it just as much this time
around
as i did the the first you know full
reading
of the series so i think there's there's
a lot to recommend these books
this is going to be a real treat to
discuss them
and that's probably enough
about my personal motivation it would be
quite interesting
those who are commenting on this video
or involved in the live chat if you
have some interesting stories about how
you got into farmer
and specifically this series i'm sure
i'd love to hear
those stories as well coming from you
now
let's pull the curtain back and start
talking
about some of the key ideas about
how the series developed about what was
going on with farmer and what he
envisioned
as he started plotting and writing these
out
having already engaged in a pretty
substantive
biographical discussion of philip jose
farmer's works and life and thought
back when we did the session on the
river world
books i don't think i need to replicate
that here
and i'd like to concentrate instead just
on the
worlds of tears series of
works and you know where the ideas came
from and at what point in time
they were percolating in philip jose
farmer's mind and i think one of the
books that's really helpful for this is
pearl's from peoria which is this
massive volume that includes a lot of
his
stories but also includes a couple cool
sections one of which
is they're titled pjf philip jose farmer
on
sf sci-fi and then pjf on pjf
and in the part called
maps and spasms he
tells us a lot about his early life
and he tells us at a certain point this
is almost at the 700 page
level of the work he says
in my senior year so 1936
i discovered dunasy and he so inspired
me that i made
notes and sketches for a story in which
a single planet
shaped like a tower of babel and having
not quite tearing laws of gravity
occupied the center of a parallel
pocket universe the only other celestial
objects were a sun and a moon and a
marine
that's what they at that time were
calling uh native americans
named kikaka roamed this exotic planet
and had many adventures
these scribblings and crude drawings
were the basis for the world of tears
series
i didn't do anything about them until
1964
however notice that's almost 30 years
right
then the tiered planet universe became
only one
of many artificial worlds and kikaka
became a
hoosier caucasian though with some
american genes
modeled on the type of person i
sometimes think i'd like to be
some people have noticed that the lords
in the second of the series gates of
creation have names out of william blake
the reason for this will be revealed in
the sixth or seventh final book in the
series
so that's an interesting little bit of
retrospective at that point in time
right
and maps and spasms is
itself from
1981
so at the time that he's writing this
he's envisioning
more world of tears books than he's
actually going to
write now you may be intrigued by this
reference
to william blake and we're going to talk
about that
a bit more later on if we have enough
time but i did want to jump into that
right away so
he tells us several different things in
a forward to one of the
collections of these these novels not
the edition that i have
but an earlier edition and he actually
tells us too
the original title for this book was the
trapdoor
planets for some reason don wolheim then
editor of ace books changed it to the
bland and less meaningful
the gates of creation he also changed my
title for the first novel to the maker
of universes
when the third book came out he changed
my title kikaka's world to
a private cosmos son of a [ __ ] i
thought but there was nothing to do
about it but complain
again and so those are the canonical
titles that we now have
a little bit later he says when i wrote
maker of universes
i did not have the origin and
history of the lords in clear detail
in my mind what there is about them in
maker was made up while i was writing
but by the time i was ready to start on
gates i had
the genesis and the outline of the
social economic psychological scientific
development
of the lords in my head i do not know
what sees me to make the
lords the same being that william blake
wrote of in his strange symbolical
and didactic works i had read parts of
these works several years before and i'd
read these and other parts in the early
1950s
at neither time had i thought of using
anything from them
though they did stimulate me blake burns
sometimes with an intense but opaque
flame
and at others with a clear and
mind-searing flame
and he has also very very long stretches
where the flame if any
is hidden my progress through them has
been somewhat like the temporal
locomotion of the tempest futures in
this book although these are these
creatures that jump ahead in time and
backwards in time
here then there then over that away with
plenty of disappearances between local
ships
but while i was working out the outline
of gates
it came to me that the lords were
actually those
cosmogens the english poet knew by new i
meant
new it seemed to me that he had not
imagined them that he had had
personal relationships with them and it
also seemed that what blake told us
about them
had been cast into poetic and symbolic
terms for some good reason i hadn't
figured out yet
now i have figured it out i
also envisioned bringing in william
blake in the last book of the series and
perhaps
having him make a brief and
unaccountable appearance
before the final volume as a teaser
i now wish that i thought of blake's
lords before i had begun
makers yadawin or wolf would have had a
different name
one taken from blake on the other hand
yadwin does sound blakian
so perhaps my unconscious the she-demon
named ebisimos
was thinking about the poet and his
works then
erazen theotoromone
what great rolling names they sound
partly ancient greek
homeric and partly ancient hebrew yet
somehow they are neither resonating in
my mind anyway
as the names of beings more ancient than
humankind more distant than the stars in
the skies
human yet not quite human godlike
assassin assassin gods
so we've got this really interesting
framing
staged at this point to talk about that
we should also mention
you know the the timing of these works
so um
you know there's the the 1950s saw
farmer kind of struggling he he actually
i will mention this not only did the
lovers come out
and it was very controversial he had the
chance to become a professional writer
he's giving him speeches at like
worldcon
becomes a technical writer there's this
shasta publishers
who gives him a first prize for all the
flesh
and he's supposed to have a actual
monetary prize shasta never actually
pays it
you know he goes back to work but
continues writing
and in 1965 same year that they moved to
beverly hills and not the good part of
beverly hills
uh he starts working for mcdonald
douglas in california
the maker of universes will come out
and this is going to be an incredibly
important work particularly
you know as we get to this notion of
pocket universes and
the sketch of the world of tears
the next year after that the gates of
creation which is a very
different kind of work but set in the
same narrative universe
is going to come out then we have a
private cosmos in 1968 so the books are
starting to space out a little more in
1970
um not only do they move back to peoria
a place that philip jose farmer wasn't
born in but but grew up in
peoria illinois by the way just south of
here right
he publishes beyond behind the walls of
terra
he also that year publishes lord of the
trees
the mad goblin lord tiger the stone god
and the stone god awakens and
this is the year before a new series is
going to emerge
to your scattered bodies go and the
fabulous riverboat are going to get
published in 1971
and there's a number of other great
works that are being published by then
the next work in this series that's
going to come out
is the lavalite world so that's that's
essentially book
five in the series same year that the
dark design in the river world series
is coming out and then there's there's
more of
of these river world things coming out
for quite a while
right what's the the next
uh book in this series well that's where
we get to something kind of interesting
so there's a book called red orcs rage
now red orc
is a blakian figure but
also a central antagonist
within the world of tears series
emerging
well mentioned actually i believe in the
second book
and then emerging as a character
in the fourth book now
why red orcs rage well because red orc
gets selected
as one of the characters that's going to
be focused on
in red orcs rage and this comes out of
the
a story so philip jose farmer
by this time had four books out right
within the
the series and actually five uh to
to be yeah five the lavalite world would
be the fifth one
so there's a rich narrative universe he
found a psychiatrist
who was using these books these novels
that he'd written
for therapy he was having his
patients take the characters within the
books and do some
some role playing and imagination stuff
and he according to farmer actually had
a pretty significant success rate so
farmer said wow that's a great idea for
a novel
i'm going to write that now red orcs
rage
is it really part of the series or is it
a meta book
about the series you have to decide and
we may in fact do a
spin-off session to talk about that
after we get through the
more canonical novels in this
this sequence but he writes that book
and he publishes it
in 1991 then
he's going to finally
get around to finishing the series
in 1993 with more than
fire which you know i'll actually give
you a little bit of a preview
going to the very end of more than
than fire um
this is kikaka who's talking right
says he would never again leave this
world the land area of which was larger
than earth's to roman it forever with
anana
one of the lords by his side would be to
live in heaven
though it would be unlike heaven and
that it had a streak of hell and he
could be killed
ah that gave it its savor my world he
shouted
and while these words sort out over the
planet they were followed
by a roar like a lion notifying
everybody that this was his territory
kikaka's world right so he finally ends
it
with the very phrase that was supposed
to characterize
a private cosmos book three in this and
kikaka really is
he becomes the most central character in
ways that we'll we'll talk about
now it's interesting that um
before he's he's actually neatly
wrapped everything up farmer isn't quite
sure
how he's going to bring the series to a
close and so there's this you know great
set of interviews with him uh one of
which is from
uh uh his apocalyptic life right
and the other is uh sex to pharah
uh 2008 so we've got a 2008 interview
and a 1990
interviews so let's look at the 2008
interview right
carlos orsi martino says much of your
sci-fi work i may mention the world of
tears and river world series
seem to me to be more rationalization
frames for wild adventure tales it seems
that you did plan
some tarzan or doc savagesque adventure
and then thought all right in which
frame can these
things be possible and then the sci-fi
worlds were built
was the process something like this and
in your mind what comes first the sci-fi
frame or the swashbuckling and philip
jose farmer says the sci-fi frame of
course
so you know the narrative universe is
being generated
a little bit later in the interview he
says when i read a feast unknown i was
kicked out of my feet it's a post-modern
before post-modernism
tarantunesque before quentin tarantino
and quite a fine yarn too it seems to
have come before its time
a little bit later in that he says why
isn't there more of your work translated
into film and comics and
and farmer says a lot of my early ideas
were too
early for tv or movies at the time they
wanted the traditional sci-fi
i have no idea why it isn't used more
now and you know we're not getting still
a lot of um
things that could be i mean this could
be easily turned into a streaming
series but it hasn't been yet as
same sort of problem with river world as
well
in the earlier interview from 1990
he's asked by in star log magazine
did the world of tears series come out
of a dream
farmer says i'm glad you asked that i
thought of the original idea while i was
still going to high school
never did anything with it then it was
an artificial pocket universe in which
there was one
babylonian shaped planet i don't know
whether i thought it up and wrote it
down or had a dream about it
anyway kikaka was originally an american
indian and he was going along
the edge of the world there he had all
sorts of adventures which i wrote down
on a notebook which i don't have anymore
but i never forgot the idea so many
years later
i incorporated it into the makers of
universes only this time
kikako was an american youth who came
back from world war ii a hoosier
same initials as mine paul giannis
finnegan
or cacao as what i would like to be but
i'm not river world's peter
yaris frigate is more like i am though
i'm somewhere between the two
more closer to frigate than finnegan
unfortunately
i finally decided i would write the
story and i did
now notice what he says here it wasn't
until the third novel a private cosmos
that i got the idea of incorporating it
into william blake's
didactic and symbolic work i never said
anything about the connection but people
who knew these works
and that there aren't too many could
tell from the names of some of the lords
that they were derived from blake
then i started shaping the connections
between them which will be
revealed in the last world of tears
series which is also mentioned in red
oryx rage now
he's already got the names of the lords
being used directly from blake in the
gates of
creation the second book so did he
misspeak there
or is it a matter of actually widening
the
use of blakey and ideas we have to
decide that right then star log asks him
again 1990 right so
shortly after red orcs rage before the
final book
what will the final world of tears novel
be
called farmer says it originally was the
garden of evil
though i may write one before that i
think the next one
will be kikaka's world and then the
garden of evil unless i decide to
incorporate them and make one novel and
just
finish it and so that
is um what he in fact did he brought he
could have done a
seven book series chose to do a six book
series you notice that the two volumes
are
a little bit different in in length
right this
all told you know the three volume the
three books in this volume are
544 pages in this book we're talking
about
a little little
uh less than 100 pages less than that
443 pages right
so the the novels are as often does
happen
with series getting a bit longer and
longer but these are all still
quite short you can easily read your way
through one of these in a in a day of
just sitting and reading it or two
and the the action is pretty fast paced
next we should talk about what these
novels themselves are and we're going to
concentrate just on the first three
contained in here we'll do a little bit
of plot
you know summary and talking about
characters and that will lead us
naturally into talking about the
narrative worlds
that philip jose farmer has created
i do want to read one more thing
before we we go however and this
is something that roger zlasny
actually had to say about
a private cosmos the third this is the
introduction of the third book of the
series
says it all goes back to my childhood of
about a year ago when i first read the
maker of universes
um i picked up philip jose farmer's book
with the green goggins sky and the grey
gog and harpy podarga on the front to
read a page or two
before beginning any work on a story of
my own i didn't do any writing that day
i finished reading the book and
immediately dashed off to my local
purveyor of paperbacks
to locate the sequel which i knew
existed the gates of creation
when i'd finished reading it the sunny
morning and saturday
and its baltimore had gone away and
night filled the day all the way up to
the top of the sky
the next thing i wrote was not my story
but a fan letter to philip jose
farmer my intention was not to tell the
man who'd
written the lovers and fire in the night
and a woman a day
that i thought these two new ones were
the best things he'd ever done if he'd
done a painting
composed a piece of music i couldn't
compare them to his stories or even to
each other
the two books i just finished reading
were of the adventure romance sort and i
felt they were exceedingly good examples
of the type
they they're different from his other
stories styles themes different even
from each other
and hence as always incomparable
i'd hoped there'd be a third one and i
was very pleased to learn that he was
working on it
in other words i looked forward for over
a year to the book you are presently
holding in your hands and considering my
own feelings to determine precisely
what it was that caused me to be so
taken by the two books i found there's
several reasons
so he says i'm fascinated by the concept
of physical immortality and the ills and
benefits attendant there too
so we're going to talk about that number
two
the concept of pocket universe is a
thing quite distinct
as i see it from various parallel worlds
notions
the idea of such universes specifically
created to serve the ends of powerful
and intelligent beings
is a neat one here it allows for among
other things the fascinating structure
of the world of
tears and then he talks about the great
characters
you know kikakis almost stealing the
first book from
wolf right the second book is packed
with miserable scheming wretched-based
low down mean and nasty individuals who
had cut one another's throat for the fun
of it
but unfortunately have their lots cast
together for
a time and he he goes on
right and he talks about uh there's this
great
passage from anthony and cleopatra
shakespeare's anthony cleopatra that he
brings up he says
beyond this what can i say about a
particular philip jose farmer's story
shakespeare said it better in anthony
and cleopatra
lepidus says what manner of thing is
your crocodile
anthony it is shaped sir like itself
and it is broad is it half breath it is
just so high as it is
and moves with its own organs it lives
by that which
nourishes it and the elements once out
of it it transmigrates
lepidus what color is it of antony of
its own color too
lepidus tis a strange serpent anthony
tis so and the tears of it are wet
zelazny goes out and he says indeed sir
they are it is the skill that goes with
the talent that makes them so
each of its products are different
complete unique and this one is no
exception
i rejoice that such a man as philip jose
farmer walks among us
rights there too there aren't many like
him none i'd say but read his story
and see what i mean
when you look at
zelazny's own work which is a prodigious
body of work and you think about
probably his most important series
the amber starts out as a five book
series then there's another
five books after that some of the ideas
that are in these volumes are showing up
including
zelazny has said one of the key themes
of the great lord who is amnesiac and
doesn't realize
that he is of this squabbling
family so that's probably enough
about that let's jump in and talk about
the narrative universe
and about what's happening in each of
these
three novels
let's talk now about the narrative
universe that
is being worked out and revealed
we'll talk about it in some respect as
it spans the six different books but
will
also focus primarily on what is being
revealed
in the first three books maker of
universes gates of creation of private
cosmos
in in volume one in part because
there's some pretty cool revelations and
ideas
especially when it comes to the idea of
pocket
universes that we'll explore much more
in the session in which we'll be
exploring volume two because there's a
lot more
exposition in in volume two about what's
happening
what we do know about these pocket
universes
in volume one is that you can reach them
from the earth
and one way you can do that is through
these various
gates right that's actually the main way
and there's a discussion very early on
where
wolf is talking with kikaka
and kikaka is talking about how he
comes back from world war ii with this
kind of interesting
silvery crescent and this guy vanox is
trying to buy it from him
and he jacks the price up really high
and vonnox
comes in and uh here we go
uh vanox is is trying to take these uh
the single half gate to get into the
other gate
he's got a flashlight it's being caught
vanished stooping over in the middle of
the living room the silvery crescent one
is in his hand
then i saw the second crescent on the
floor vanex had brought another with him
i'd caught him in the act of placing the
two together to form a complete circle
i didn't know why he was doing it but i
found out a moment later i told him put
his hands up he did so
but lifted his foot to step into the
circle i told him not to move even a
trifle or i'd shoot
he put one foot inside the circle anyway
so i fired i shot
over his head and the slug went in the
corner of the room he backed up
and i walked across the room while he
backed up towards the door he was
babbling like a maniac threatening me in
one breath
offering me half a million in the next i
thought i'd back him up against the door
and then jab
the 45 in his belly he'd really talk
then spill his guts about the crescent
but as i followed him across the room i
stepped into the circle
formed by the two crescents he saw what
i was doing
and screamed at me not too too late then
he in the apartment disappeared and i
found myself still
in the circle only it wasn't quite the
same and in this world
in the palace of the lord on top of the
world and so this is the
the workings of a gate and that's the
main way that people get from one
pocket universe to another there is also
this
horn that plays a major role actually
throughout the entire
series and it's not just a macguffin it
gets used a lot
to open up junctures between worlds
where there's
there's the possibility of gates
now the next thing that kikaka says is
really interesting and here's where
philip jose farmer is you know kikaka
represents him in a certain way as he'd
like to be
and notice what he's going to say kikaku
said he might have gone into shock then
but he had
avidly read fantasy and science fiction
since the fourth grade of grammar school
the idea of
parallel universes and devices for
transition between them
was familiar he had been conditioned to
accept such concepts
in fact he half believed in them thus he
was
flexible minded enough to bend without
breaking them to bounce back
although frightened he was at the same
time excited and curious
this is a very interesting passage
involving a kind of
self-referentiality not just to philip
jose farmer as the
author but to his readership he's
he's telling us he's signaling us listen
i'm working with an idea
that is not radically new
going from here to there through some
kind of magical
gate the possibility of there being
multiple universes notice that he
doesn't say pocket universe is there
which is going to come up
later on which is a somewhat different
concept
but the idea of going from one world to
the next
in an instantaneous way not
involving travel across space but going
directly from one portal
to another philip jose farmer is saying
if you've read your sci-fi and fantasy
you know
from an early age this is not a a
puzzling thing for you and when it
happens to you
you won't be driven mad by
the shock and so i think that's quite an
interesting uh observation
that he's he's uh weaving in there right
and this isn't a discussion between two
of the main
characters of the entire novel arc
so what happens well you know we start
out in earth
and that is going to be one of the main
locuses
of the entire six book series
although it's not going to become a
major
locus until the fourth book the third
book actually concludes with them saying
okay we've got to go to earth now
and we're going to learn some cool
things about earth that i won't tell you
right off the bat if you haven't read
those
and the other places that are going to
be particularly important
are the world of tears the place
where wolf finds himself going after he
blows the horn
and goes through the portal we're going
to explore that shortly
but in the second book we have another
world another pocket universe in which
there are
planets small planets circling a
central planet which was created
by um wolf's
jodowin's father and the father of so
many of the other characters that we're
going to encounter
who are part of these people called the
lords
right so what we've got is
book one we leave earth and we come to
the world of tears
we get to explore it to a certain degree
we're kind of you know rushing through
the
different tiers and we'll talk about
what we mean by tears in a moment
then the second book involves wolf
having to go to this other
place this other dimension this other
pocket
universe uh trying to find his his
you know wife consort whatever you want
to call her girlfriend
chris uh who is the you know the one
from
the iliad and um
he winds up in essentially a trap that
was created
by his his uh father or maybe not
maybe um
by his sister vala
and so that that action is happening
after the first novel the second novel
is
sequential the third novel is actually
happening
at the same time as the second novel
and it's shifting emphasis away from
wolf and these other lords to
kikaka who's been introduced in the
first right
and who's a good friend of wolf and
another really important um lord figure
gets gets introduced there
as well um who is
is you know kind of uh conventional at
the start but also
very tough very resilient very smart
ananah or anana right rather
and then we get a final i won't i won't
read that little revelation just in case
you haven't read the books about who the
lord of earth
actually is because that's going to come
in when we look at the
second series and so we've got some
really major main characters
all of whom are either lords
or are human beings who possess
extraordinary abilities and it's hinted
that perhaps they could be
half-lords or something like that and
then we have a
vast variety of human beings
none of whom end up being uh major
characters
in their own right um
in part because the series is just not
designed that way
there are some who play important roles
for a short amount of time
but none who really span the entirety of
the
series so what we've got in terms of
setting
is this incredibly imaginative world we
already talked about
you know the interview where farmer says
well i make the worlds and then i make
things happen within them right
so let's talk about this world of tears
just so you can wrap your head around it
if you haven't read it already this will
give you at least a guide if you have
read it this will be
refreshment so this is
just actually coming from the wikipedia
overview right
the pocket universe in which the world
of tears is located contains only three
astronomical
objects there is an and this is uh
there are all these names and they're
almost all unpronounceable
uh aleph methben the throne name for the
world of tears though is another name
for lords right
a single moon orbiting the world of
tears
and a single tiny star also orbiting
this
there's light coming in but there isn't
actually
any any sun in it and
here's a little excerpt from from a
private cosmos
the surface area on all levels of the
planet that is the horizontal area on
the tops of the monoliths
equal the surface area of the watery
bodies of
earth has made the land area more than
that of earth's
in addition the habitable areas on the
verticalities of the monoliths
we'll talk about what those are in a
minute were considerable
these probably equaled the land area of
earth's africa
moreover there were immense subterranean
territories great caverns and vast
networks that ran
under the earth everywhere so what he's
created is
in terms of just sheer spatiality
a cosmos in which the world
contains much more space than our
earth and why is it a world of tears
well think of it like a layer cake
except instead of the cake
having the layers all pressed on top of
each other
you've got a layer and then there's a
monolith that goes up a
massive like axis and then you have the
next layer on top of that
and then you have another monolith going
up and it goes
from the very bottom level all the way
up to the
palace of the lord at the very top and
there's four
you could call them
levels that are not the the lord's level
in which
human beings interact with each other as
well as with a lot of crazy animals as
we're gonna
find out and so at the very bottom
there's okianos
which is in large part ocean
and it's it's a sort of edenic kind of
area there's plenty of fruit growing and
nobody has to really work for a living
and you can get as drunk or high as you
want to
and screw whenever you want to and
people just kind of you know sort of
like the
island of the lotus eaters in the
odyssey
and there's uh you know human beings
there and there's also
dryads and there's zebrarillas
sort of a gorilla that looks like a
zebra stripe thing
all sorts of other cool things as well
and this is actually populated
by people taken from ancient greece
around the time of the trojan war and
some of them have been
you know just taken there and their
bodies have been modified to a certain
extent
some of them have been placed inside of
animals their brains have been
transposed into you know all these other
kinds of things the next level
up which you reach by
climbing this this monolith uh which the
first one is called
thia fey awoid
right uh again crazy names that that
farmer made up for these then you get to
the american
indian uh called in the book a marind
which was
just you know a common use term at the
time
particularly in the 60s and 70s
and this area is
is you know mostly land with you know
rivers and stuff like that as well
and a great trade route and it's
populated by
people taken from north and
central america so there's aztec like
civilizations
there's civilizations that you know bear
strong resemblance to the plains tribes
there's a bunch of other things going on
as well and as we're going to find out
in the third book
there's also some vikings that got
plopped down
a part of the area as well then you know
you climb up another
monolith and you get to drakkaland
which is you know they're they're saying
medieval arthurian but it's really
more it was it was knights taken from uh
crusades against the the
you know the heathens in in the baltic
area that were like
you know plopped out and taken there as
well as
some some jewish settlements as well
and it's uh you know it's quite
interesting to see that the
transformations that are taking place
here
and then finally there's atlantis that's
the fourth level
and you know radimanthus is supposed to
be the
the king of that that's more or less
devastated by the time
that we get to these stories in this
book
was a major civilization now it's been
turned into
ruins and jungle in part because of the
machinations of the lord who has taken
over yahweh's palace
or jodowin however it's supposed to be
pronounced and so there's monoliths with
each of these
and if you if you climb the final
monolith
which you don't necessarily have to do
there's there's a workaround that they
find in the first book
uh the final monolith is idiquizuru
right then you are in the palace of the
lord and the lords
are these incredibly ancient beings that
look like us humans
but um have augmented their abilities in
many ways
many of them have been living for you
know quite a few thousands of years
their civilization has been around for a
long time
as we're going to find out later on in
the the
subsequent books human beings were
ultimately you know
generated by them
and the lords do whatever they want with
their universes they set them up in
whatever they
way they want to they can be great
places they can be terrible places
they pull people from other pocket
universes or from earth
which is exactly what jodowan did when
he was lord
he took you know people from ancient
greece he took native americans
he took these germans and just you know
plunked them down
and allowed their civilizations to
continue on
in their own trajectory he also filled
up these lands
with some uh interesting animals you
know some of which
are animals that lived on earth but have
been extinct for quite a long time you
know for example lions that are even
bigger than the lions we know
uh bison that are that are even greater
than the bison that we know
but he also did a lot of messing around
with
animals within the bio labs right so he
could create a new interesting
versions in fact later on in the story
we find out that
the uh world of barsoom
you know mars in the burrows thing is
created
on the moon not with every one of the
creatures but
at least with with quite a few of them
and so you know we've got this really
interesting
um you can't call it a civilization
because it's actually a whole bunch of
different civilizations
pushed into each other interacting with
each other
and you know kikaka who's been
in this world for quite a long time
since the 40s actually
um he has aliases
on each of the each of the levels right
and he got in there kind of randomly as
we saw and then you know
uh assumed in existence that he really
enjoyed um
in this this world so we've got these
these main characters and we should talk
about
so we've got kikaku who's a trickster
figure right
and who is daring and and you know does
all this this cool
stuff and he um
he's connected with wolf he's the one
who throws the horn to
wolf in the first place and in the in
the first novel kikaka
comes in and then you know he's he's
there at the end of the the story but
he's not
the main character the main character is
wolf
who turns out to be the lord who's just
amnesiac and we're going to explore that
that um
trope in in just a moment um in the
second one
we're now in this other universe
and there are these planets orbiting a
central planet
each of them is set up in different ways
they're kind of in
you know kind of kooky places right one
is primarily a water world
and there are these floating islands
that can also go into the sky
and there are gates to get from one of
these to the other
another is a essentially a world of
of glass you know where um
they're you have to move around with
sucker pads or skates that's what the
the native fauna have and then there's
there's yet another one
which um is uh
covered with skin yeah i guess you could
say
and so there are all these interesting
worlds
and you move from one to the other with
these these gates and ultimately they
have to get to the the final world where
um you know everything is going to play
out and and the
big puzzle will get solved and uh
in those in that second book um
there are all sorts of uh brothers and
sisters and cousins the gates of
creation
um there are all sorts of uh um
other lords or thons involved most of
whom are
you know kind of jerks we're going to
talk about that in a moment as well
as one of the key themes a few of which
turn out to be
unusual like vala
or turn out to be unusually beautiful
and also deadly or
also turn out to be kind of reliable and
decent
which which only turns out to be one
brother
of um of joduin and in the third book
um we get to we're back in the world of
tears and we get to see
a lot more of what's going on on each of
these
levels the third book also introduces a
really
important plot point that is going to
run
into the fourth book as well and that
has to do with the black bellars
and this is the introduction of
mechanical intelligence or a.i
in a very deadly way in the storyline
and it also brings together kikaka
and ananda
a lord lord you know lady i guess you
could say but lord
in her own right into this love story
that's going on as well
so that gives you at least some idea
about
what's happening in the
the world what the universe looks like
what it is that
philip jose farmer has created
for us to to think about his
his literary playground you might say
one interesting theme that i'd promised
earlier that we'd get to in this session
which we don't have to devote an awful
lot of time to
is that of the amnesiac
person who has their identity
revealed to them and as it turns out
they are
one of in this case a lord ortho on one
of the
important people right and we know that
this
is an old trope that gets used prior to
farmer
we also know that farmer himself
influences people like zelazny who you
know waxes poetic about how great this
this stuff is and who has corey or
corwin
in um the chronicles of amber at first
not quite know who he is until his you
know memory is
restored through walking the pattern uh
so this is this is a very
common theme and it shows up well at
least it's set up early on
in the work just on page eight right
he says there had been times when it had
been easy to whine or weep how many men
could remember
nothing before the age of 20. he thought
it was 20
for the wolves who adopted him and said
that he looked that
age he'd been discovered wandering in
the hills of kentucky near the indiana
border
by old man wolf he'd not known who he
was or how he had come there kentucky
or even the united states of america had
been meaningless to him
as had all the english tongue
and then the wolves take him in notify
the sheriff
and because it's world war one
you know it doesn't attract a lot of
attention the the newspaper is full of
that
and he says uh worse than his lack of
formal knowledge had been his ignorance
of how to behave
time and again he'd embarrassed or
offended others he'd suffered from the
scornful or sometimes savage reaction of
the hill folk
but had learned swiftly and his
willingness to work hard plus his great
strength in defending himself
had gained respect in an amazingly quick
time as if he'd been relearning
he had studied and passed through grade
in high school
although he had lacked by many years the
full time of attendance required he'd
taken
and passed the entrance exams to the
university with no trouble
there he'd begun his lifelong love
affair with the classical languages
most of all he loved greek for it struck
a chord within him
he felt at home with it and so you know
he
he becomes a academic and and goes on
and
this is before he enters the world of
tears or rather
re-enters it as we're going to find out
because it is indeed
his world we get a little foreshadowing
of this
uh when he's talking uh with with
uh elecopsis right
and she tells this story you know
once a long time ago i was one of his
favorites meeting the lords
whenever he came down from the top of
the world to visit here he would spend
much time with me
chris and i were the ones he loved the
most would you believe it the others
still hate us for it that's why i'm so
lonely not
that being with the others is much help
and so wolfe asks her what did the lord
look like and she says
from the neck down he looked much like
any tall well-built man such as you
his face wolf asked i do not know i
could feel it but i could not see it a
radiance from it blinded me
when he got close i had to close my eyes
it was so
bright and um you know
as it's going to turn out that was wolf
or
jodowin or yarwin as as the lord
and towards the end of this this first
book the maker of
universes we find that
wolfe is starting to put two and two
together
he realizes at last who he is in part
through talking
with another lord who they
they had prisoner for a while and it's a
bit dangerous
because he and kikaka
are lined up with with uh podarg who's
the you know
harpy depicted on the cover right this
uh very powerful uh
half woman half bird creature who was
put into this body
by jodowan the lord long ago and who's
who's trying to wreak revenge upon him
along with her great eagles as well
many of whom were originally human
beings too
and so we get to this this point
where um here we go
there's a slip of the tongue right and
he says
he and kikake had not wanted to reveal
the identity of a bureau until later
podarg hated the lord
so much that she would have killed him
at once wolff wanted to keep him alive
because vanex if he did not try to
betray them
could be valuable in the taking of the
palace
and you know wolfe says the old saying
goes you can't trust the lord
podark says what did you say and i
repeat who
is vanex and you know she she doesn't
know the name
but she's already getting quite
suspicious about
wolf and you know it goes on further
um kikaka or wolf says in a low voice to
kikaka he was a traitor but he did as a
service i meant to try the same trick
only i was going to use the horn and
he's pretending
to like figure these things out but
actually
he's he's the lord you could say
not in disguise although he is in
disguise from podark
but he's he's now had his identity
restored to him
but it's a somewhat different
identity so if we go on a little bit
further um
[Music]
here we go uh
yadawyn i did not recognize you until i
saw you with the horn i thought you
looked familiar i should have known but
it's been a long time
how long it's been many centuries he's
talking with the lord who took over his
palace
or millennia depending on the time scale
so we old two old enemies face each
other again
but this time you have no way out you
will die as vannux
died and then um wolf says
or this is wolff's perspective suddenly
he was seized with a concern and sense
of injustice
if podag should kill our war the lord
who'd taken over
from jodowan's place she would not be
killing the man who is responsible
for her present state it was he who had
done that to her
it did not matter that our war would
have done the same thing if he had been
lord of this world at the time
on the other hand he wolf was not to
blame
either he was not the lord jodowan who
had constructed this universe and then
manipulated it so foully for so many of
its creatures and abducted terrestrials
the attack of amnesia had been complete
it had wiped out it wiped all of jodowin
from him and made him a blank page
out of that blankness emerged a new man
wolf one incapable of acting like
jodowin or any of the other
lords and he was still wolf except
that he remembered what he had been the
thought made him sick and contrite and
eager to make amends as best
as he could and so this is a really
interesting
conundrum isn't it it there there are
other tv shows and movies and
and and stories where people discover
that
they are in fact the bad guy right and
and that's
what wolf himself has realized he's
at least not the bad guy but a bad guy
and the one who so negatively
affected all the people within his
domain
that perhaps he does deserve to suffer
but on the other hand
he's also the one who rallied them to
you know take back the palace of the
lord so this is a very
interesting thematic and it really only
has to do
with with wolf but you could say that
the reverberations of that run
throughout
the other books in particular because
in the second book that is even affects
the third and
later books um wolf
being the way that he is as
as jodowan slash wolf makes things
possible for the other lords
possibilities that most of them don't
take up
but could have and so now we should turn
to talking about the lords
as a key theme this
class of the lords at first introduced
in the singular
in the maker of universes and then
expanded into
the plural in that same book as kikaka
helps a wolf understand the situation
and the the universe that they're in
this theme is uh quite important
and there's a lot of different
wrinkles to this that we can explore
but the first thing that i want to say
is that there's
clearly a problematic
for the lords of what we can call the
problem
of immortality and power they have great
power
compared to human beings and
even in relation to each other and
they they have to figure out what to do
with that but there's also this key
theme of immortality they take drugs
they have treatments that not only
augment their bodily abilities which are
you know pretty great to begin with
but can extend their lifetime
indefinitely
and then the question is well what do
you fill that time with
and how does that affect you as a person
and your relationships and this is a
classic theme as well
farmer of course is not coming up with
this
but he's got a very interesting take on
this
so we first start getting some
exposition
about this with uh kikaka
talking about the uh land that's
and the amer india level of the tears he
says
you know take a look at this you know
this level is not flat it's got a series
of slight curves
those allow water to run off creeks and
rivers and lakes to form there's no snow
but it rains every day the clouds come
in from space everywhere so it's a it's
a pretty well designed piece
and then kikaka
talks through wolf's turn at guard and
he says
and here's what we get from it in the
beginning a long time ago
more than 20 000 years the lords had
dwelled in a universe
parallel to earth's they were not known
as the lords then
there were not very many of them at that
time for they were the survivor of a
millennia-long struggle with another
species
they numbered perhaps ten thousand in
all but what they lacked in quantity
they more than possessed in quality
cacaca said
they had a science and technology that
makes ours
earth look like the wisdom of tasmanian
aborigines
they were able to construct these
private universes
and they did at first each universe was
a sort of playground a microcosmic
country club for small groups
then as was inevitable since these
people were human beings no matter how
god-like in their powers they
quarreled the feeling of property was
was is as strong in them as in us
there was a struggle amongst them i
suppose there were also deaths from
accident and suicide also the isolation
and loneliness of the lords made them
megalomaniacs
natural when you consider that each
played the part of a little god
and came to believe in his role to
compress
an aeon's long story into a few words
the lord who built this
particular universe eventually found
himself alone
yadawyn was his name and he did not even
have a mate of his own kind he did not
want one
why should he share this world with an
equal when he could be a zeus with a
millionaire europas
with the loveliest of leda's and then he
goes on a little bit further
and he says the only trouble was the
lords were not content to rule over just
one universe they began to covet
the worlds of the others and so the
struggle was continued they erected
nearly impregnable defenses and
conceived almost
invincible offenses the battle became
a deadly game this fatal play was
inevitable this is a very important
point here
when you consider that boredom and
anyway were enemies the lords could not
keep away
when you are near omnipotent and your
creatures too lowly and weak to interest
you forever
what thrill is there besides risking
your immortality
against another immortal and so this is
a
really key aspect it's not just hatred
it's not just envy or or rivalry
or things like that there is you could
say almost an existential need for
at least many of the lords to face off
against each other
because otherwise the mere pleasure
seeking
and domination of their you know play
things
human beings other animals it falls
short even even the capacity to build
weird new universes after a while
isn't giving them the charge that they
need some of them do kill themselves
others as we're going to find devote
themselves to
furthering that science but what we find
is that the lords that we're dealing
with here
are in some ways you could say
degenerate they they don't have
everything that the lords in the past
did and so this is kind of a
an important issue right so
the lords themselves
[Music]
as we see very much in the second book
gates of creation they
they don't know what to do with
themselves when they're not within their
domains and
some of them seem to
lose any sense of purpose or ambition
altogether so they have a civilization
but
their civilization is such that
the lords now the lords of the present
they can't actually develop anything new
all they can do is take the old stuff
that they already had
and reconfigure it they can use the
machines they can use the technology
but they don't understand the technology
and so
they're they're in in many ways a
declining
civilization when we go
on to the
[Music]
the lords as we find them
we we get that they actually have
some sort of connection with um
blake you know there's there's something
going on that connected them
with him and with
uh you know all these these crazy names
and there's there's sort of
phil jose farmer inserts this really
interesting
idea that blake himself had encountered
that particular family of
lords meaning wolf jodowans
uh brothers and sisters and cousins and
and
you know mother and father and all that
and
reproduced that in in his own works
you know a theory that we find just
farmer putting
forth so his narrative
his narrative characters are
in this narrative universe supposed to
be
the blueprints for a real life
mystic uh blake right so that's that's
kind of an interesting
feature as well but what's really
important with this
is that the lords themselves as a
family you know this particular
clan we could say they they basically
can't get along
and they're ready to kill each other
including vala
parts in particular who is you know very
dangerous
turns out to be masterminding the
terrors and traps and tricks and puzzles
that they have to go through
vala actually at one point says
enough of this childish bickering don't
you know that when you quarrel amongst
yourselves you delight the heart of our
father
he would love to see you tear each other
apart and so they're only able to have
like a
pact against their their father
because they all hate him so much and
they're so angry with him
and then wolf says vala is right you
call yourself lords
makers and rulers of entire universes
yet you behave like spoiled and evil
brats if you hate each other
remember that the one who taught you
this horrible hatred and who now is set
the stage for your death
still lives he must die if we have to
die ourselves in making sure of his
death be
be so be it but at least try to live
with dignity
and so dignify your deaths
um you know this this actually provokes
a counter response from one of his
brothers who calls him a foundling
and in a way wolf is actually a
foundling because he's a foundling to
the wolves
and he is through that
you know bringing a very different
perspective to
to these you know the possibilities for
these
lords so one of the questions that we
can ask
that i think is well worth delving into
is can
a lord genuinely
love and we know that that you know
wolf for example loves christians and
he loves kakaka as well right so
that's that's clearly uh true
you know um
but can can other lords love and
you know there's there's an interesting
point that gets brought up
um particularly from this this one
brother
luva who in blake's cosmology is
connected with love right
and here's where you see wolf
and his one brother that he gets along
with
working out their relationship he says
you were always too impetuous brother to
rash yet i feel honored you would
forsake your safety to visit me only
only i should have been much more
careful more sure that the messenger was
from you
at another time i might have been uh
then
wolf is silent for a while and he says
we're in the most desperate situation
we've ever faced lava
the greatest peril of course is our
father but almost as deadly are those on
whom we have to depend
most despite their word of honor this is
his other brothers
and sister they will always need
watching i propose we support each other
when i sleep you watch
when you sleep i stand guard lova smiled
one-sidedly and said and when you sleep
you will keep one eye
open to watch me hey brother wolf
frowned
and lava said hastily don't be angry
ottawa you and i have managed to survive
so long because we never
fully gave our trust with the best of
reasons
how sad it is that all of us our sisters
brothers and cousins
once lived and studied and played
together in innocence
and even love so love was there
originally love could take place again
he says yet today we are as hungry
wolves at each other's throats and why i
ask you why i will tell you
it is because the lords are mad they
think they are gods
when all the time they are only human
beings really no
better than these savages here
only they happen to be heir to a great
power science and technology
which they use without understanding the
principles behind it they are
as evil children with toys that create
whole worlds and destroy
whole worlds the great and wise men who
devise the toys have long since died
knowledge and science have died out and
the good inherent in the cosmic powers
is twisted for their benefit and theirs
only and then wolf says i know that well
brother
better than you perhaps since i was once
as selfish and vicious as those others
yet i underwent an experience which i
will tell you about sometime
it changed me into a human being i hope
into a being only you have the ability
to appreciate and so this is a very
interesting
exchange between the two right it's
telling us more about the culture of the
lords
it's telling us more about
what we could say farmer
is casting as the
way forward for the lords who
genu generally can't recognize it they
they view trust they view love they
view you know long-term relationships
that are not just based
on you know self-interest
and a kind of paranoia as foolishness
uh is a prime example of that
wolf's sister and sister to many of the
other lords
in that book who turns out to have
orchestrated the
entire thing it wasn't their father who
did it
her fa their father is prisoner and
she is the one who brought them all in
there to torture them
over you know months and maybe even
years and
ultimately kill all of them so
that's another interesting feature is it
not
and then in the third book right
in the private cosmos
we get a very different kind of
relationship developing we have
uh ananna right uh or yeah
anana yeah who is it's always always
tripping up with with her name um who by
the way
is podarg's face was modeled after so
that
produces some interesting uh exchanges
between the two of them
she is a lord who is you know
coming into jodhwan or wolf's world the
world of tears
along with two other lords in order to
escape the black bellers that we'll talk
about
subsequently and she runs into kikaka
they wind up being together for a while
she expresses the possibility that you
know
um she could be attracted to him he's
not quite sure
what to make of that she's clearly a
dangerous person herself
she also has a you know kind of elitist
racist attitude and uses a slur word for
human beings to describe
kitkaka and he tells her if you do that
again i'm going to kill you
and over time they come to trust each
other
and then to appreciate each other and
then
to love each other to desire
each other to desire the love from the
other one and it's really only confirmed
you know towards the end
when kikaka is going through this
cyclical
gate and ananna jumps in
ananda jumps in and tries to save him
even though she doesn't have to and it's
at great risk to herself she does so
kind of spontaneously by the very
end they are lovers they will remain
lovers throughout um the rest of the
books
as well which is kind of a cool feature
and you know she justifies it to herself
by saying
you know maybe you're actually the child
of the lord
you're you know you seem pretty uh you
know with it
you've got all this strength all these
abilities and
things like that so that that provides
her with a way of justifying it but she
she does in fact
fall in love and not so much in this
book itself but
in the other books becomes a better
person
and a better lord through that
so you know i think that is a kind of
interesting
arc that um
farmer is building into this this story
by the way i i will mention one last
thing when it comes to the love thing
and then we'll talk about the
black bellers farmer is known for
graphic depictions of of sexuality
the after effects of sex sexual acts
desire
what people have on their mind and
there's not i mean there's there's you
know naked people in it
but there's not an awful and there is
sex people do have sex in this but
there's not an awful lot of
you know semi-pornographic depictions
as we saw in you know the earlier farmer
like with the lover
or things like that in a way he doesn't
have to do that anymore right he
he can do the and then they went off and
you know had a good time
kind of dodges and and that's what you
know
these uh uh various
lords and and their human companions end
up
doing the last big
philosophical theme that we're going to
have time for here is to talk about
the black bellars and what we're talking
about there
is really technology specifically
something like an artificial
intelligence
gonomoc and trying to
eliminate or rather colonize
the the lords and by doing so to take
over
um all of the different pocket universes
and you know to rule over all the human
beings as well
and they first come up and all of this
is in a private cosmos
and so they don't play any real role in
the first two books
but the entire third book is dominated
by that and the fourth book is going to
be
pretty important as well and so
anana brings up the black bellers
she suggests that maybe giadawin was
killed by them
and kikaka says black bellars
wolf had spoken to them at one time but
briefly because their conversation had
been interrupted
uh later he intended to ask him about
that
and so you know we don't really know
that much about it and kikaka says
ananna called the bright was one of
wolfe's sisters
she'd use he'd used her face as a model
when he created poe darg's face in the
bio lab
um kikaka remember now wolf had said the
black bellars were to have been used
partly as receptacles for
memory the lords knowing that even the
complex human brain could not hold
thousands of years of knowledge had
experimented with the transfer of
memory this could theoretically be
transferred back to the human brain when
needed or
otherwise displayed exteriorly right so
these black bellas are now
you know after them and a little bit
later on we get some
interesting exposition as a matter of
fact the entirety of chapter seven is
almost taken up with that right
so we're going to go through some of
that
um an anana says
let me see how to begin the black
bella's were originally an artificial
form of life
created by the lord scientists ten
thousand years ago
the scientists created the beller's
during their quest for a true
immortality
so the idea was you would transfer
your memories essentially your entire
brain
into the bell of the black bellars and
she says
a bellar is a bell-shaped black of
indestructible material
even if one were attached to a hydrogen
bomb the bellar would survive the
fission
or a bellar could be shot into the heart
of a star and it would go unscathed for
a billion years
so that's you know some pretty cool
sci-fi right there right
and he says the scientists originally
constructed it so it was purely
automatic it had no mind of its own it
was a device only
placed on a man's head it detected the
man's skin potential
and automatically extruded two extremely
thin but rigid needles
these bored through the skull and into
the brain through the needles the
bellower could discharge the contents of
a man's mind it could uncoil the chains
of giant protein molecules composing
memory
and it could dissociate the complex
neural patterns of the conscious
and unconscious mind and so cakaka says
well
what would the why would a lord want
that what's what's that good for
right uh wouldn't the the person be a
tabula raza
and an ana says yeah that person would
so the lord in their their body their
brain
is now basically a vegetable but you've
got the bell
and you can stick it on somebody else's
head somebody younger
somebody in better shape somebody who
isn't at the end of their body's life
cycle
and you can re-inject that entire
memory personality all the stuff right
so
you can download it you could say into
the
the other person and then you can live
through them
for another you know 10 000 years or
whatever
and this would allow lords to live on
for millennia perhaps millions of years
if no accidents homicide or suicide
occurred right
and
[Music]
she goes on and she says the bellars
were to provide a means whereby the
mental contents of the lord could be
transferred the brain of a host
so you know the lord could live on in a
new body while the old one died of its
its womb its wounds so the bellar was
constructed
so that uh mental contents of the lord
could be stored for a very long time if
an emergency demanded this
it contained a power pack and it drew on
the neural energy of the host
to charge the power pack and then
kikaka brings up an interesting problem
he says
this isn't really survival of a of a
person though
this is and this is kind of like the
transporter
issue in star trek right when you
have yourself whatever yourself is could
be a brain
could be your whole body broken down
turned into another format then
reconstituted again
you've actually died haven't you and
so you know he goes on he says this
stripping dematricizing scanning and
duplication doesn't seem to me to be a
true immortality it's not like pouring
the mental contents
of one head into another it's not a
genuine brain transference
it consists in reality of recording
cerebral complexes forebrain and i
suppose hind brain too
to get the entire mind or don't bellers
have unconscious as well destroying them
then running off the records tapes if
you will to build an identical brain in
a different container
the brain of the second party however is
not the brain of the first
party in reality the first party is dead
and through though the second party
thinks that it's the first party
because it has the brain complex of the
first party it's only a duplication and
then
ana says a baby speaks the wisdom of the
ages
that would be true if there were no such
thing as the psyche
or the soul as you humans call it but
the lord's had indubitable proof that an
extra spatial
extra extra temporal entity co-evil with
every sentient being exists
even you humans have them these
duplicate the mental content of the body
or soma
anyway the psyche is the other half of
the real person and when the duplicate
soma brain is built up in the bella the
psyche or soul transfers to the bellar
and when the bella re-transfers the
mental contents to the new host the
psyche then goes to the new host
so that's an interesting way to get
around this
this is also a theme that shows up
you know throughout the entirety of
philip jose farmer's river world series
right
where people who have lived on
earth throughout you know from the
beginning of time to
i think as of the 1980s or something or
maybe the 2000s
are all resurrected in
new bodies that are you know in the
prime of life
and their souls are reattached to these
bodies or re-inhabit these bodies this
is exactly the same thing that he's
talking about here
so that's that's a pretty important
farmarian
theme right and it's not tied in with
religious
conceptions it's really just sort of a
physical thing
that that happens um kikaka actually
says
do you have any proof of this and she
says no we don't have any direct proof
but
you know we we we've been assured the
proofs existed at one time
going on about the bellers kikaka says
okay so
what the bellers are like former lords
and she says no
no here's where it gets complicated
here's where it gets tricky
they came to realize they started a new
research
program essentially scientists
accidentally discovered
an unused bell had the potentialities
for developing into an
entity that is an unused bell was a baby
bellar
if it were talked to played with taught
to speak to identify to develop its
embryonic personality
it became not a thing a mechanical
device
but a person a rather alien peculiar
person
but still a person and he says in other
words the framework
for housing a human brain could become a
brain in its own right
she says yes the scientists became
fascinated they made a separate project
out of raising bellars they found that a
bellar could become as complex as an
intel
and as intelligent as an adult lord the
original project was abandoned
um and she says no one knows what really
happened there were ten thousand fully
adult
bellars in the project and a number of
baby bellars
somehow a bellar managed to get its
needle antenna into the skull of the
lord
it uncoiled dematricized the lord's
brain then transferred itself into the
host's brain
thereafter one by one the other lords of
the project were taken over
possessed in effect right turned into
you know the the the tool which has now
become its own
entity takes over the tool maker
and turns it into a host and then
replicates throughout the system
and she goes on she says at that time my
ancestors were creating their private
custom-made universes
they were indeed lords gods if there
ever were any the whole universe
continued to be the base for the stock
population
many of the bellers and the host bodies
managed to get out of the home universe
and into the private universes
by the time that the truth was
discovered it was impossible to know
who had or who had not been taken over
there had been so many transfers
almost 10 000 lords had been
as it was termed beld so there's a war
that goes on 200 years
and she's born during that time by that
now this
this is where we're getting some of the
backstory that's telling us how did
these lords wind up being so screwed up
you know
how did they wind up in this situation
where they got this amazing technology
and nobody actually knows how to operate
it
by then most of the lord scientists and
technicians had been killed
over half the layman population was also
dead
the home universe was ravaged this was
the beginning of the end of science and
progress
and the beginning of the solipsism of
the lords
the survivors had much power and the
devices and machines in their control
but the understanding of the principles
behind the power and machines
was lost they managed to find all but
50 of the the bellars
and the nine thousand nine hundred and
fifty were placed into a special
universe created for them
they couldn't find the other fifty and
they created rings that that anana has
uh to detect the bellers right and she
you know she says somehow human beings
must have come across the bellers and
the whole thing
started anew and that's what gives us
our you know our plot points for the
beller's are taking over
and possessing people in the world of
tears
and you know they have to fight them
eventually they kill all except for
one who escapes and guess where he
escapes to
or it escapes to to earth
and so they they they say let's get
ready to
go to earth and and find them
um here's a little exchange at the very
end of the the third book
um
ananda shakes her head and laughs
there's many things that a person
did remember things which beller could
not possibly have known
um he's my brother all the way through
he's not a bellar
you know and then they they go on a
little bit talking more about that
where are we going to go to find it
earth we're going to have to go there
and track down the beller and that's
going to lead us into the next series
the bellers are a
you know quite interesting
antagonists are they
artificial intelligences in the way that
we typically think of it
not quite because you know we usually
think about like computers
and you know maybe linked together as
like skynet and the terminator
but we think of solid-state computers
as um the core of those artificial
intelligences
here it's less of a computer and more
a storage device itself that has
sensorial capacities the bells can
actually
sense some things and the bells
are as as you know farmer has on an
assay
they be the baby bellars turn into
entities
into persons rather than just being
mechanics but they are
mechanical so how should we
understand them this is a very
interesting
question that is more or less
left unresolved by the end of this
there'll be a lot more speculation about
all of these topics and the topic that
we didn't get into
too much about pocket universes
when we move into the next volume
containing the
fourth fifth and sixth look in this
series
[Music]
you